in the lobby of Ramsey solutions
solutions hunter and Kelty are with us
hey guys how are you better than we
deserve are you Dave I know than I
deserve where you guys from Fort Worth
Texas all right and all the way to
Nashville to do a debt-free scream yep
congratulations how much have you paid
off just under seventy four thousand way
to go and how long did that take eleven
months Wow
and your range of income during that
year 110,000 boy any go cool what do
y'all do for a living I'm gonna count it
and my wife's a nurse oh good very cool
74 thousand dollars I mean you must have
sold something or had some savings or
something how'd you do that we got
married about a year ago and we had
about $20,000 in our bank account from
just goes together and we all case we
through all that and then you did beans
and rice for 11 months that's right yes
okay so getting marrieds what started
the whole thing
it is all right cool what made you
decide to do this because not many
people when they get married go I'm
gonna have no life for a year we when we
got married last May we we wanted to get
on the same page with our finances and
so we took your FPU about a year ago
from now and it was just such a blessing
for us to kind of align our goals from
the get-go from starting our lives
together and there so you took it during
your pre marriage time or write it as
newlyweds newlyweds
oh okay Wow okay so what made you was it
just offered at your church and that
kind of okay we got to do that or how
did it come up yes are our parents have
done it before and they encouraged us to
do it and our church was offering it so
okay don't be you baby so okay all right
cool very cool how old are you - I'm 25
and Kelty's 24 awesome man this is so
cool that's so neat because now it's a
generational thing your parents went
through it both of your parents did
that's wild
yeah you guys are completely
indoctrinated yeah so you had some
cheerleaders then within the family
people going yeah yeah yeah do it do it
my parents wish they had done it earlier
so they encouraged us to do it right
away
very cool so what kind of dad I'm
guessing Sallie Mae all student loan
debt was all student loans okay Wow
so you had to give the old lady her
eviction
his first order of business when you're
married yep that's right get Sally Mae
out of the house kick her out get to the
road your woman I don't want you around
here I love it very very cool
well it's kind of neat it's like really
super neat when you start this out as
one of your first things because now you
know you can a work together and be you
know you can handle money and you got
the rest of your lives ahead of you to
have this benefit in your marriage but
also to be able to just build wealth you
guys are in great shape sir way to go so
what was the hardest part I mean you're
it said you had all the advantages I
mean you started when you weren't
married I mean when you're just freshly
married so you hadn't really got a bunch
of bad habits yet and you got families
supporting you that believed in it so
you had a lot of good things on your
side but what was the hardest part I
think the hardest part was moving twice
we were living in downtown Fort Worth
paying a high amount on our apartment
rent and so we moved outside of the city
to save about 500 a month whoo I'm just
on rent and then we decided to move
again about three months ago to take a
part-time opportunity where we helped
plan the events at our new apartment and
that's they give us a discount on rent
there as well okay very cool so even
cheaper rent yet yes sir very good very
good oh gosh how's it feel you have any
payments it feels great it it's I mean
we're free it feels awesome feel like we
can we can do it we want Keltie what was
the most important lesson you all
learned through this process I think the
most important part and what I encourage
my friends and they asked me about it is
just be willing to change make the
change that you need to in order to live
underneath you're mean and to make the
difference and one of the greatest
things that we learn to value throughout
the FPU course was that it was a great
reminder that this is not ours nothing
that we have here nothing our money the
things that we have it's the Lord's and
so we just valued stewarding that well
above all else not really helped yeah
that's kind of a higher calling it gives
a higher purpose to not going out to eat
it gives a higher purpose to I'm getting
out of debt because if you know we're
managing this money for God and God says
clean this mess up and I'm gonna clean
it up definitely yeah
that's a big deal you're right so
Hunter what do you tell people the
secret to paying off seventy four
thousand dollars in 11 months is to
start with have twenty grand in the bank
throw at it that's really yeah I think
it's I mean it's just as much about
cutting out your expenses as it is your
income people focus a lot of times on
what they're making and they don't
realize if they just cut the cable cut
out other certain expenses that that has
just as much of an impact as on the
bottom line as your income does how's it
feel to not have a payment in the world
it feels great feels great we're in baby
step three so we're on a way to fully
funding an emergency fund and then start
saving up for our first home Oh way to
go you guys well congratulations I'm
very proud of you we're gonna give you a
copy a signed copy of Chris Hogan's
number one bestseller retire inspired
because that's the next thing to do
stewarding your money has become wealthy
and live like no one else and now you
can live like no one else and give like
no one else as you build this wealth and
you guys I predict you'll be
millionaires very very quickly and
that's pretty cool that's pretty cool
that's good stewarding is what that is
excellent job hunter and Kelty Fort
Worth Texas seventy four thousand
dollars paid off in 11 months brand new
marriage did it with a hundred and ten
thousand dollar income count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one awesomeness very very very well done
that's how you do it hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or twenty
seven thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000 in
common